[Music]
today I want to tell you why I'm
thankful for angular and talk about some
of the advantages that it offers over
other front-end frameworks if you follow
Twitter you may have seen the state of
Jay s survey results were just published
the other day and what you will have
learned from this survey is that
everybody hates angular and everybody
loves view and react but as you'll see
over the next few minutes that's not the
actual reality that we live in if you're
new here like and subscribe and please
let me know what you think in the
comments because this is a very
important topic I'd like to start by
saying that I'm a big fan of react and
especially view and this video is
nothing against those frameworks or the
developers that use them but it is a
problem when flawed data is used to
represent the entire JavaScript
population because product managers and
developers will use this data to justify
their decisions so I've done my fair
share of data analysis I'm a top-ranked
Cabul expert and I can generally pick
out when we're dealing with a bad data
set one of the most common ways to screw
up a data set is with a sampling bias
now I'm not implying any mal-intent by
the creators of this survey they
actually did an awesome job with the
user interface but they're all involved
in the react community which just makes
it more likely for the survey to be
distributed among react developers as
opposed to the JavaScript community at
large and we can actually see this in
the data itself we have about 20,000
total respondents with 13,000 being
happy react developers now if we look at
the statistics for angular will see that
the exact inverse is true for developers
who dislike or have no interest in
learning angular now react was
definitely the most popular javascript
library in 2018 I'm not doubting that
but what we're seeing is a flaw in the
satisfaction rate even though everybody
says it's not a competition it's
definitely competition if you've
invested a lot of time and either one of
these frameworks you want to see your
own framework succeed and the big red
flag for me was in the framework
conclusion section where the author
talks about the fall of angular which is
simply not true outside of the echo
chamber of this survey and we'll look at
some supporting hard data in just a
second here another problem with the
sample as that the majority of the
respondents come from the United States
with a very small percentage of females
and for some reason the average salary
is way higher in the United States than
it is in reality I think most people are
probably just lying about their salary
or maybe the survey got distributed to a
high percentage of Facebook employees
working in the Bay air
and on a similar note this survey only
had 20,000 total responses my little
youtube channel has 70,000 subscribers
so that just puts in perspective how
small this actual sample is of the total
developer population I'm gonna go ahead
and leave it at that
I think this survey is fun but it's not
something you should use as the basis
for important decision-making so now
let's look at some hard unbiased data
that we can use to get a picture of the
true state of JavaScript
none of these metrics are perfect on
their own but we can use all of them
together to get a general idea of how
things sit the first thing we'll look at
is NPM downloads and we can do that on
NPM trends comm angular View and react
all grew in 2018 but you can see at the
beginning of the year react was getting
about three times more downloads than
angular and in the last six months
that's been reduced to about one and a
half to two times more downloads and
views held steady at a distant third
place but you could say ton of downloads
in China from other sources so keep that
in mind the next thing I want to look at
is jobs first we'll check out Stack
Overflow and if we search react jobs you
can see we get seven hundred and
fourteen results but if we then go
search for angular you can see we get
three hundred and eighty results so the
ratio aligns almost perfectly to NPM
downloads the next thing we'll look at
is freelance job postings on up work
here we'll find about a hundred eighteen
jobs for react and about 66 for angular
and again we have roughly the same ratio
the next thing we'll take a look at is
an article on medium that claims that
78% of the front-end developer jobs or
four react and this is based on job
postings on indeed if we go to indeed
and type in react you can see that
that's absolutely true we get way more
postings for react but if we actually
look at this data they're not react jobs
they're construction jobs with an
average salary of $15 an hour so when
you read an article online don't take it
at face value
make sure to scrutinize its data because
a lot of people just make honest
mistakes and a lot of people just
[ __ ] so if we look at the actual job
postings on indeed we can type in react
developer or react web and do the same
for angular and we get an even
distribution of jobs and most good
companies will hire based on your
JavaScript and programming fundamentals
not just the fact that you know a
specific framework and the last thing I
want to look at is web traffic to the
documentation for these various
frameworks we can grab this unbiased
data from Alexa and it should show the
same trend that we see in the survey
with Angry
on the decline and react on an uptrend
but we actually see the inverse of this
trend with angular's documentation site
receiving more web traffic than react in
2018 and view J s actually generates the
most web traffic most of which comes
from China but it's interesting that
this trend is the exact inverse of what
we see in NPM downloads
there's probably additional data we
could look at but I'm just going to
leave it there and hopefully that gives
you a better picture of the real state
of JavaScript now I want to take a few
minutes to show you why angular has been
so successful over the last couple years
because angular has some pretty awesome
superpowers that you won't find in
reactor view so in no particular order
we'll start with routing in react
everything is a component or a function
so that leads to some pretty cumbersome
routing you kind of get used to doing
things this way but when you go to
angular or view it's very refreshing
we're just looking at the view router
QuickStart and what you'll see here is a
router that's directly embedded with the
component HTML I really like to maintain
a separation of concerns in my code and
I feel like this just violates it and
complex nested routing gets even more
difficult to deal with if you look at
the angular router you define all your
routes is a plain JavaScript object so
it's very clear and easy to understand
we have a path and then that path routes
to a specific component we don't have to
do all this weird component stuff just
to define some routes and if we look at
the view router here quickly it kind of
takes the same approaches angular which
I think just makes a lot more sense now
the next reason I'm thankful for angular
is the CLI the angular CLI is just in a
completely different universe when it
comes to generating boilerplate code
testing and being extendable in addition
we now have the angular console which
makes the CLI much more approachable to
newcomers and allows you to use
everything in a graphical user interface
the officially supported CLI tool and
react is create react app and it doesn't
really do a whole lot
it will scaffold out your initial
project but it doesn't generate
components and you'll probably end up
ejecting from it after generating the
initial boilerplate the vcli is not
quite as powerful as angular but it does
have a really nice UI and it gives you
the option to mix and match different
packages and generate your project with
typescript so it does offer a lot of
nice options and it seems to constantly
be getting better the next huge reason
I'm thankful for angular is dependency
injection it seems kind of weird to a
web developer at first but it's a really
simple concept
you have an app with multiple components
and you want to share some state or some
functionality between all those
components this is a requirement for
virtually every JavaScript app and it
becomes very hard to do as your
component tree grows more complex in
react you basically have to either use
the context API which is just kind of
like root scope from angular 1 or you
have to use a library like redux which
is going to dramatically increase your
code footprint on an already complex
project but with angular you can just
create a service and then inject it into
any component that you want this allows
you to separate your concerns very
easily no matter what your component
tree looks like now the last thing I'm
thankful for is how angular reduces
complexity a lot of people complain that
angular is too big and bloated but
that's only because other frameworks
tend to hide their complexity and it
doesn't really come out until you get
into a complicated app so let's take a
look at a simple react component and
then we'll switch over to angular so
with react we have a state object which
may become hooks in the future which
aren't really much different then we'll
define a render method which returns
some JSX and this is actually another
reason I'm thankful for angular learning
and using JSX is pretty annoying because
it's kind of like HTML but it has all
these small caveats that make you use it
in a different way than you would use
regular HTML for example if we want to
add a CSS class here we can't just say
class equals whatever we actually have
to use class name because class is a
reserved word in JavaScript this isn't a
huge deal of course but it does feel
like a weird abstraction to have when
building a web application and with JSX
you'll tend to run into code readability
issues for example if we want to loop
over a list of items we'll need to
extract this out into its own function
or we can just map it to a Dom element
directly in the JSX
so you either have to D structure your
HTML into multiple functions or you have
to embed this JavaScript directly in the
template which is hard to read in my
opinion so let's go ahead and switch
over to angular and we'll build this
exact same component the nice thing
about angular is that it uses typescript
which both angular and view are starting
to adopt as well so I'm thankful for
that as well and if we want to define
our data we can just define them as
properties on this class then angular
allows us to write our templates like
their regular HTML with some additional
magic on top so instead of writing a
JavaScript loop we can just use the ng
for directive
you loop over the items in our array so
we can write out our template with a lot
less code and a way that's more readable
in my opinion assuming that you know
what energy four does so the idea that
angular is more complex than reactor
view is really just kind of nonsense if
you've watched my channel for a while
you've seen me build out all kinds of
different demos with angular which would
just generally not be possible with
react because there's additional
configuration to get through again I'm
not saying one's better than the other
but really just wanted to highlight some
of the best parts of angular in this
video let me know whether you agree or
disagree in the comments and again make
sure to be critical of data that's
floating out around there on the
interwebs whether it supports or goes
against your worldview I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there I'm
wishing everybody a happy Thanksgiving
and I'll see you next week
[Music]